so much in the world is about moving  fast  but moving fast has actually broken a  lot of things  it's broken our trust  it has undermined our confidence in many  of our systems of governance perhaps  even our faith in democracy itself  by slowing down a little bit and  bringing the conversation in  by listening with sincerity debating  with respect Consulting widely and  weighing difficult decisions with candor  you can actually build systems that  endure but most importantly you can  build trust that quality that is in such  short supply right now and Trust in one  another is what we need in order to  weather uncertainty and take brave  action